since taking the helm of the FBI
director Christopher Rea has avoided the
harsh spotlight and headlines of his
predecessor James Comey who was fired by
President Trump and the year into the
job Christopher raised most important
task is to help restore the reputation
of America's top federal law enforcement
agency we spoke to the FBI's new boss
for an exclusive wide-ranging interview
over two days in September he told us
he's working to rebuild trust
after harsh attacks on the bureau's
integrity from our nation's commander in
chief the president has said that he
wants the Attorney General to
investigate who wrote that anonymous New
York Times op-ed do you believe as the
President does that this is an issue of
national security
well first off I can tell you I didn't
write it I don't have anything to do
with it
second I would tell you that we're not
really in the practice of confirming or
discussing whether we're going to be
conducting a particular investigation I
would tell you that we're gonna make
decisions about that kind of thing based
on all the factors we normally do which
is whether or not we have sufficient
evidence of federal crime you said you
did not write the Maritimes out that I
know that you have denied that but but I
want to ask you about the content it
described the president's leadership
style is quote impetuous adversarial
petty and ineffective it said that the
root of the president's promises quote a
morality does that sound like the
president you know I try very hard to
make sure that my relationship with the
president is a professional one and
beyond that I'm not going to really be
weigh in on opinions especially
anonymously expressed opinions I can
tell you that there are lots of ways for
people to express their views and their
disagreements for me the idea of doing
it through an anonymous op-ed is about
the furthest thing from my mind mm-hmm
what do you think is the appropriate way
to do it I think that depends on the
circumstances and if you had a
disagreement with the president how
would you raise it again depends on the
circumstances I think it starts by
having a direct conversation it depends
on what the issue is you're here you
live in Washington so you also know that
much of this town is also talking about
Bob Woodward's book called
year and in that book he describes an
administration which you are part of but
he's specifically describing the White
House as having a nervous breakdown of
executive power have you experienced any
of that I have not seen a nervous
breakdown of executive power I have also
not read mr. Woodward's book and I'm not
sure whether I'll ever find time how
would you describe your relationship
with President Trump my focus is on
having a very professional relationship
with the president I think that's what
I've been trying to do since day one and
that's true today just as much as it was
on day one do you meet with him
one-on-one
no you usually meet with the Attorney
General the Deputy Attorney General well
I certainly had plenty of meetings with
the president I just haven't met with
him one-on-one I usually meet with him
with a small group of other people and
it depends on what the issue is he
tweets a lot about cabinet members and
top members of his administration but
you specifically have never been the
subject of one of his tweets well I'm
not much of a Twitter guy as people will
tell you and that's not meant to
criticise Twitter at social media
commentary has its place I just find
that I've got enough to do all day long
running the FBI that without getting too
hung up and worrying about what's on
Twitter mm-hmm let me turn now to Russia
and its malign activities when Vladimir
Putin said that Russia has never
interfered and is not going to interfere
in American affairs including the
election process was he lying I'm not
gonna accuse somebody of lying I'll just
say that that doesn't jibe with our read
of the evidence and we're pretty
confident in our read what is Russia
doing to disrupt the midterms that are
now just about 60 days away so what
we're seeing now is a continuation of
the what we call it the malign foreign
influence efforts what they do is so
both inaccurate information
disinformation it's the kind of
information warfare and then propaganda
exaggerated hashed truths distortions
and they do both by in clandestine and
covert means they fan it out through
social media and try to pit Americans
against each other and they took
quickly will seize upon you know some
social issue and try to gin up both
sides so that we turn on each other
and so we've known that for several
years well I think what has been
happening for a number of years but it
continues to happen relentlessly to this
day and the the use of social media is a
bullhorn that allows that kind of
information warfare to be inflicted much
more effectively so that's why it's
something that remains a concern and
could influence individual voters if
we're not as Americans vigilant about
who's saying what and where their
information is coming from as director
of the FBI I know you created this
foreign influence task force to try and
funnel some of this actionable
intelligence on so some changes could be
made how has that changed things how has
that made the election process safer
well the foreign influence task force is
something that we created last year to
bring together the different disciplines
of the FBI which is designed to do a
number of things one is to make sure
that we ensure that we have the right
kinds of investigations throughout all
of our field offices whether it's a
counterintelligence investigation a
cyber attack a criminal investigation
all of which are designed to deal with
that we're also doing a better job of
communicating with state local election
officials about information that they
should have working close to the
Department of Homeland Security and then
of course we're also working very
closely with the private sector
especially the technology sector in
order to help them be more effective and
aggressive in protecting their own
platforms from abuse in fact just in
april facebook announced that it had
dismantled or taken down hundreds of
accounts that were tied to the internet
research agency which is essentially a
Russian troll farm that is pushing out a
lot of this information warfare when
Facebook did that was that based on the
actionable intelligence from the FBI
well I can't discuss in this kind of
setting specific intelligence specific
investigations but what I can tell you
is that we have a much much closer
working relationship
if the prominent companies in Silicon
Valley where we share information with
them they can take certain steps and
then they share information with us and
we get sort of a back and forth that's
very much for the best benefit of the
American people why are we letting this
happen
why are we letting Russian do this we
have the greatest law enforcement agency
in the world the FBI we have the most
powerful tech companies in the world why
are we allowing Russia to do this I
don't view us as allowing them to do
anything
I think we're countering it we are
working hard to counter it more more
effectively all fighting back well in
some cases we have law enforcement
investigations that lead to charges in
some cases we have steps that the
technology companies can take themselves
and in some cases were raising awareness
because the best defense against
disinformation and propaganda is
accurate information and the more the
American people are careful about what
they're hearing and who they're hearing
it from the more protected we are
there's a top priority for you it
absolutely has to be our democracy is
one of the things that we're most proud
of in this country and we rightly so is
it a top priority for this White House I
think it is I think the the fact that
you had the FBI director the Director of
National Intelligence the Secretary of
Homeland Security the head of NSA all
together along with the National
Security Advisor
holding a conference together as a
reflection of how seriously we all take
this subject that was just once in
August well I don't want to measure our
efforts by by a press conference but I
think that's a reflection of what we're
doing we have lots and lots of meetings
behind the scene and more importantly at
the levels below us we have lots of
people working very hard to protect
American clarify that then because while
the FBI has been working and other
agencies have been working to counter
this election meddling there are some
who have said there is no one driving
this bus there's no one from the White
House who's in charge making sure that
the communication is going on when was
the last time that there was a White
House meeting on this issue I mean we've
had a number of meetings I don't know
that I could think through on my
calendar when the last one was but we've
had quite a few over the last several
months
so not a concern for you the number of
meetings well that there's cordon
within the government on this issue that
it's a top issue I will say I've heard
that complaint I think it's a red
herring to be honest what I find when I
talked to our folks when I talked to my
counterparts at Homeland Security or NSA
or odni the Director of National
Intelligence or elsewhere in the
community the CIA etc everyone's focused
on and everyone knows what their jobs
are everyone's working hard so come
November when the tally is announced of
the votes can Americans be confident
that it was a fair election I think
Americans can have confidence in our
election system we talked about the
intelligence assessment that Russia is
trying to weaken and divide the United
States there was a Pew poll out recently
about the reputation of the FBI and it
showed a 28-point
partisan gap in terms of how the FBI is
viewed 77% of Democrats were positively
supportive of the FBI forty-nine percent
of Republicans amongst Republicans
that's fallen 16 percent in just the
last year why do you think there are
some questions about the reputation of
the FBI well I think sometimes watching
the news and certainly trolling the
Internet you would think that the FBI
has only had two investigations over the
last three years but I will tell you
that when you get out into real America
people know differently I've been to 43
already of our 56 field offices and
we'll get to all 56 in short order
I've met with something like 2,500 of
our state local and foreign partners I
met with prosecutors I've met with
victims I've met with judges and in
office after office what I encounter
from the people who actually experience
the FBI through our work is a very
different story and we're not driven by
poll numbers there's one thing the FBI
is not about it's poll numbers we're
about the work and about the people we
work for and that's the American people
that's the victims that we're trying to
protect from whether it's kidnappings or
terrorist attacks or gang violence
that's what we're about
do you feel like you have support from
the White House for the FBI's mission I
do I think we're doing what we need to
do I don't really get too hung up on and
I don't think our folks get too hung up
on what's on social media to be honest
we're much more driven by what to our
partners think of us what are the
prosecutors think what are the judges
think what are the juries think what are
the victims and their families think
what of all our federal state local
foreign intelligence community partners
think do they know they can count on us
and over and over and over again the
feedback I get from those people who
know what they're talking about
is uniformly positive and appreciative
directory I know you have been asked
this many times but I do want to ask it
of you because the president has issued
repeated attacks on the FBI on the
integrity of its work on the people who
work here at the FBI in fact he said
that the reputation of the FBI is in
tatters those attacks I have to have
taken their toll I'll tell you what I
see I see 37,000 men and women who get
up every day trying to keep 325 million
American people safe I see people who
work their tails off in that effort who
are people of character of courage of
professionalism and diligence and we do
thousands and thousands of
investigations every year I think about
the agents that I swear in at Quantico
several times a year who compete like
heck to be accepted into the ranks of
the FBI I think about the Chicago agent
the SWAT agent that I thought about the
other day who got shot at point-blank
range by an ak-47 lost the use of his
dominant hand retrained himself to shoot
with his other hand Rhee qualified for
SWAT and then not only said about going
back to work in the mission but to being
a good mentor to an ATF colleague who
had also been shot I think about the
woman in Miami I met who 12 stitches in
her face injured back at it the next day
I think about the guy in Portland that I
met just recently one of our
Tech's who got peppered with shrapnel
from a booby trap that he encountered
when clearing a house back at work the
next day I could give you an example
after example that's the FBI that I see
that's the real FBI and that's what
we're about I mean you're the leader of
an incredible organization the FBI and
all of us are members of different
organizations and when sometimes someone
insults our organization we tell them to
cut it out have you told the President
to cut it out I'm not gonna comment on
my discussions with the president I will
say we're big boys and girls we're used
to criticism there's a lot of opinions
out there by a lot of people and a lot
of settings we're focused on the work
and the people we do the work for you've
addressed this issue but the scathing IG
report that followed the last election
specifically into Hillary Clinton's
emails did that hurt the FBI's
credibility well I think the Inspector
General's report speaks for itself in
many ways and it's 500 something pages
long I would say that we ran it picked
by both sides well we're an organization
that's a hundred and ten years old that
and we're an organization 37,000 people
and I would say that just like any
organization we've made our share of
mistakes over the years what defines us
ultimately is whether we learn lessons
from those mistakes and we have done
that over and over again including in
this instance and come out better and
stronger from it and that's what's going
to happen here let me ask you about the
Catholic Church it has been in the news
as of late and there are now attorney
generals in several states that have
launched investigations into the
Catholic Church and abuse by priests at
what point does this rise to the level
of a national investigation where the
FBI would get involved I'm not going to
be discussing whether we're going to be
conducting a particular investigation or
not I would tell you that in my view
there is no set of victims in this
country that are more worthy and more in
need of our protection than our kids and
I think it's a point of pride for
everybody who works in the FBI that we
fight for those who can't fight for
themselves
and I will also say that when we have
the facts and we have the law and we
have the evidence to support an
investigation there is no institution
that were afraid to investigate period
now we've done lots and lots of work to
keep kids in this country safe from lots
of different kinds of predators just in
the course of this year alone we've
rescued something like thirteen hundred
thirteen fifty almost fourteen hundred
kids
rescued them how so these would be kids
who have been kidnapped or abducted or
exploited in some way it's something we
take very personally the FBI yeah the
FBI is on the front lines of taking care
of children rescuing them amongst all
the other things that they do right and
we view our job as both to get the bad
guy and to get the child back the issue
of attacks on journalists the president
has frequently called the press the
enemy of the American people the FBI
just recently foiled a plot against the
Boston Globe where the man had
threatened to essentially shoot up the
newsroom and he used the phrase enemy of
the people is the FBI investigating
threats to journalists we do have a
number of investigations involving
threats to journalists just in the past
the course of this year I would say
we've got maybe a half dozen or so
investigations of threats to journalists
in particular but that's not counting
all the ones that we work on with our
state local law enforcement partners as
well certainly for example we have the
active shooter situation in Annapolis
with the paper there we work closely
with our state and local counterparts to
try to be of assistance there we have
our evidence recovery teams of earnest
response teams we have our lab we have
our SWAT teams so we do a lot of things
to deploy but in my view threats of
violence much less actual violence to
the news media is something that we
cannot and will not tolerate it
let's turn to China and the efforts of
China here in the United States would
you say that China has been more
successful than Russia in terms of
infiltrating American intelligence well
I do think that China that there's no
country that presents a more broad and
more comprehensive threat to our ideas
to our innovation to our economic
security in many ways to so much of our
daily lives than China does and that
takes a lot of different forms and it is
the FBI's top counterintelligence
priority and it needs to be so our men
and women are grinding away on this
issue day in and day out your top
counterintelligence party is China it's
not Russia we spent a lot of time
working on Russia - but if I look at our
counterintelligence mission overall
China is our top priority in that space
we've had cases involving everything
from turbine technology in places like
upstate New York to corn seed
development in Iowa what do you mean
corn see they're trying to steal our
corn seed well of course we have I think
America's agriculture is the envy of the
world and we're very proud of it and we
should be and whenever we're the best at
something somebody else is chasing us
it's something that I think most
Americans don't understand what are they
trying to steal what do they want
they're trying to steal our trade
secrets our ideas our innovation our
assets if you will our ideas it sounds
like we're under attack well I don't
know that I would use that word but I
would say that we are in a situation
where there is widespread intellectual
property theft economic espionage cyber
intrusions and those are things that we
are going to fight back against the US
Trade Representative put a figure on the
theft of intellectual property and it's
up to six hundred billion dollars
annually it's enormous
the thing that people need to
is that this has an impact on everyday
people it has an impact on American
businesses it has an impact on American
jobs it has an impact on American
consumers how so well China's goal is to
take what it can and become essentially
self-sufficient and put American
businesses out of business
well to replace America as the world's
economic superpower I think that's their
goal and they're pretty open about I
will stack our innovation our system our
people up against any but it's a threat
that's real and it's something that we
need to take very seriously and it
involves not just the Chinese government
it involves Chinese businesses both
state-owned businesses as well as
Chinese ostensibly private businesses
that advance the Chinese government's
agenda or in some cases are even
directed by the Chinese government it
involves not just traditional spies you
know the old-school spy versus spy kind
of thing but also other types of people
who are sent here by China either
pressured or incentivized to steal
information and bring it back to some
arm of the Chinese government I mean the
FBI has indicted professors in the past
what threat did they pose Chinese
professors well I have to speak can't
speak to any specific case but certainly
we have situations where we have
research scientists who come from China
who work in very sensitive fields of
study that are very relevant to our
national security that involve National
Defense Information there's a very close
an appropriate partnership between the
scientific community and our defense
infrastructure in this country and some
situations there are academics who take
that information and bring it back to
the Chinese but I think as you were just
saying they're not traditional Chinese
spies they're in academia they're in all
kinds of different fields that are
carrying out this type of economic
espionage that's right these are people
who are in some cases research
scientists in some cases businesspeople
in some cases other kinds of research
some cases they could be students more
likely graduate students and
undergraduate students in some cases
they could be students again not for a
minute do I want to suggest that all
Chinese visitors are somehow up to no
good
not at all but there are lots of them
and we have lots of investigations
ongoing as we just discussed how many
arrests is the FBI made of Chinese spies
I don't have that number handy billa
Vanina who's the country's top
counterintelligence official he told CBS
News that China was dedicating ungodly
resources to espionage and that it was
more aggressive than ever he said that
the FBI had arrested more than two dozen
Chinese spies well depending on the time
period I have I'm quite confident that
would be an accurate number it just
depends on what time period we're
certainly I think we probably arrested a
lot more than that depending how far
back in time you go since 2016 5 current
or former employees some of whom worked
here the FBI have been charged with
espionage so what is the FBI doing to
make sure you don't have spies here well
what you're describing there is what we
call the insider threat and that's
something that we and the rest of our
partners in the intelligence community
are very focused on which is situations
where somebody already working in the
intelligence community is recruited or
co-opted by a foreign intelligence
service in this case the Chinese and one
of our core missions going back 110
years is to protect America from that
threat and we investigate it very very
aggressively and carefully and we intend
to continue doing that given the scope
of that Chinese espionage and efforts to
steal our American technology that could
be up to six hundred billion dollars
annually what's the FBI doing to
counteract that how do you do it how do
you prevent the stealing of wind turbine
technology corn seed technology
everything that's out there that they're
trying to steal well it starts with
vigilance and so even though we are
devoting lots of resources
of agents analysts and professional
staff to lots of investigations in this
space in order to be able to get the
kind of coverage that we're talking
about here we need to make sure that
we're partnering more and more closely
with American business with the private
sector with American universities and
we're doing a lot these days
all over the country to meet with and
engage and brief those institutions
whether their companies or research
institutions and to try to encourage
them what to be on the lookout for and
in many cases they can take steps to
protect themselves which helps us all in
this common fight it is a many ways that
kind of a whole of American society
defense here and just to drill down on
this to give you know our viewers just
kind of a sense of what's going on this
was public than in August a General
Electric engineer was arrested for
stealing plans for power turbines how
did the FBI find out about that well I
want to be a little bit careful what I
say about a specific investigation other
than to say that we partner very closely
with American businesses and a company
like that is a classic example of a
situation where they have certain
expertise access infrastructure we have
certain expertise agents and might and
working together we can come up with a
solution so more broadly speaking since
you've been FBI director are some of the
great American companies coming to you
and saying we think the Chinese are
trying to steal some of our best
technology we one of the things that's
been most gratifying to me in my first
year on the job is how committed and
enthusiastic a lot of American
businesses are to working with us in
this common fight and we have found
situations where they've come to us now
that they know better what to be on the
lookout for and we encourage them to do
that it's the whole see something say
something in a very different context
and we usually use that expression and
then we often will ourselves reach out
and tell them something we're seeing and
sometimes that then prompts a very
productive conversation it's not only
these individuals who are engaged in
spying its companies you've raised
concerns about the Chinese telecom
Giants
Huawei and ZTE why are they national
security risks well anytime you start
talking about foreign companies that are
beholding to foreign governments that
don't share our values and our
dedication to the rule of law enables
them to conduct economic espionage it
enables them to conduct different kinds
of cyberattacks it enables them to steal
information in a variety of ways the
president intervened a few months ago to
save ZTE from some of these crippling
financial penalties that Congress wanted
was the president wrong I continue to be
very concerned and I think the
intelligence community continues to be
very concerned about the threat to our
telecommunications infrastructure
presented by some of the kinds of
companies that are beholden to foreign
governments that don't share our values
and the idea of letting the Fox in the
henhouse is something that I think
people need to be really really careful
about before we find out that we're
going to regret it when you talk about
your tenure as FBI director you've been
in office just over a year now has been
a tough year how would you describe it
you know it's had its challenges of
course but I knew that coming in I think
that this is an organization that has
some of the greatest people in the world
and has one of the most important
missions in the world and I think it's a
privilege to be able to work with these
people and as I make my way around the
country then to 43 of our 56 field
offices and met with them I've met with
every headquarters division I've met
with a whole bunch of our offices
overseas over and over and over again
I meet unbelievably inspiring
hard-working dedicated people who come
from all walks of life who are unified
by one thing which is to protect the
American people and uphold the
Constitution and I feel very lucky to be
a part of it much less as the director
mm-hmm your predecessor was fired James
Cohen was fired by the president United
States did you want this job I was not
seeking this job I was in private
practice I thought my law on force
the days were behind me and I was doing
quite well in private practice but when
the opportunity arose and I started
talking with some of my friends from the
FBI who had been agents that I worked
with when I was a line prosecutor in
Atlanta who were agents who worked at
headquarters when I was here on and
after 9/11 the thought of coming back
into this space was exciting to me and I
believe so strongly in their mission and
in their character that the opportunity
to do it was something that I didn't
think I could pass up you've been called
a steady hand described as understated
and that you give everybody their day in
court what is it that you want the
American people to know about you that
they may not know my mantra my motto
that I've expressed over and over again
to our folks is keep calm and tackle
hard and that basically boils down to
there's nobody yelling or screaming or
anything else that's gonna get the FBI
off track as long as I have anything to
say about it we're gonna focus on the
work on the mission which is protecting
the American people and upholding the
Constitution everything else is noise so
in the midst of a lot of partisan
bickering and back-and-forth you're what
focused on the mission that sounds like
I think what the American people should
expect deserve from the FBI and from the
FBI director is straight shooter and
that's what they're gonna get thank you
thank you